and if I talking to his chest can you
get a picture of this guy's this is why
we picked the book everyone has said to
me why did you pick the book this is why
we came I want to welcome you tonight I
want to thank you all for coming out for
our first annual Gwinnett reads picnic
my staff prepared a wonderful script for
me to read to introduce this man if
you've read the book you don't have to
be introduced to him you know about it
if you've read anything that he's ever
read you realize that he can put words
together in a wonderful way I do have to
say fill out your evaluation forms I do
have to say during the question and
answer period please use that mic right
there I do have to say thank you so much
to all of our partners who have made
this possible and I do have to say thank
you Rick Brad
well there there been a lot of firsts on
this as first time I've ever been a
human microphone before megaphone yeah
the microphone never the first of all
you know with with dead seriousness
thank you all this is wonderful
I appreciate it I truly do second of all
usually about halfway through these
things I take off my author jacket which
I paid $49 for it the big and tall store
in Metairie
but I'm so wired up and I got so many
cables on me I'm gonna head like a pig
but if I can begin to jerk and smoke up
here with somebody knocked me down and
pull these wires off on me because I
realize it might be quite funny to see a
six-foot to 260 pound man jerking and
dancing across the podium but it
wouldn't be that good for me so so thank
y'all the fact that the Gwinnett County
picked all over but the shouting is
there community-wide read is is very
flattering to me and and and that so
many people have turned out to talk
about it and more than that to tell me
that I stole their story is in a in a
way even more flattering and you know
who you are you were in line a few
minutes ago and and I did steal your
story I really truly did I stole the
story of anybody who grew up in the
North Georgia Mountains
I stole the story of anybody who grew up
along the Alabama Georgia corridor I
stole the story of everybody who came
from South Pennsylvania I stole the
story of everybody who ever worked with
their hands for a living and I certainly
stole the story of all you people who
are descended from people who worked
with your hands just cause we're in
Gwinnett County don't mean we can start
putting on airs
just as a little experiment by show of
somebody get a bucket of water right by
show of hands how many of you people are
descended from people who work with
their hands
you came from people who swung hammers
you came from people who dug coal you
came from people who climb ladders you
came from people whose scrub floors you
came from people who pick cotton you
came from people who made whiskey some
of us by the way I really want to thank
the gentleman who stood in line and told
me that yeah I remember my uncle used to
go over to your granddad said let's go
to Charlie bun rooms and get some
whiskey now that might not make my
aunt's too proud but it makes me proud
but yeah well here he is and that just
tickles me to death it tickles me when
someone has a personal connection to the
book it tickles me especially when
people who were strangers to me feel a
personal connection to that book you
don't have to know Margaret Bragg or
Charlie Bundren to have a personal
connection to those people and I can
spend the rest of my life I got a cousin
in the audience I got to be careful but
I could spend the rest of my life
writing about those people and never get
tired and never get bored and never feel
that I need to write about anything else
and probably will spend the rest of my
life writing books about my people as
long as I'm able to write them as long
as I can find a publisher for them we
have a two book contract to do two more
books about the people of the foothills
of the Appalachians with Knopf and you
know that's kind of like getting an
engagement ring you know if you want to
you're probably going to get to get
married although then again it is me
talking
I have been dumped by a few dozen good
women a lot of time but when it came
time to write the book about my my mom I
knew that it would be the most important
thing that I ever wrote also knew that
it would be difficult I knew that I
would have to explain my dad to show
what I consider my mama's heroism these
are not things that I say because I like
to say them my momma really did go 18
years without a new dress so that I
would have school clothes she really did
wait to eat until we were done her sons
were done not because there wasn't food
there but because she wanted us to have
the best of what was there
that's why I've looked like this
well that and the fact that I once lived
right around the corner from the zest
O's on Ponce de Leon Boulevard but my
mama really did drag me up and down a
million miles of cotton field so that I
would have a chance to come here and
talk to people like you and before
anybody asked who's not accustomed to my
accent yes I really do talk this way but
she really did do all those things but
to write her story I had to first
explain my daddy and some of us know
what it's like to have a daddy that
loses his finer nature throughout the
course of their life sometimes through a
bottle sometimes through a war sometimes
through a lot of things and when it came
time to try to explain my daddy I you
know being a southern rider I wanted to
find a metaphor or simile because it
makes it easier to explain painful
things if you can paint a picture for
someone to sit up and talk about things
like that especially if you're a
southern man is really hard because we
don't like it daytime TV stuff you know
we ain't never gonna have there's
somebody to grease with it dr. Phil
ain't never gonna explain my inner rage
to me
so the only way I've ever been able to
tell a story is by painting people a
picture of it and when I was trying to
explain my daddy who went off to Korea
and fought in a war he was a Marine
when I was trying to explain what might
have happened to him there to affect
change in his life when I thought about
him killing a Chinese soldier by holding
his head under a frozen stream with his
bare hands I knew I couldn't just leap
into that story cuz it broke my heart so
I look for a metaphor or a simile and to
be real honest with you I don't know
what in the hell the difference is
between a metaphor and assimilate
roomful of librarians and I have to
admit I don't know my grammar so I was
looking for that picture and it occurred
to me that maybe maybe there was
something that it I'd seen is a little
boy that might explain it and I
remembered this image that had ridden
with me all my life of a cardinal
y'all have Redbirds here some people
call them Cardinals but most all of us
just call them Redbirds and I thought
about something that I'd seen is a
little boy that had just haunted me and
it occurred to me that it was the
perfect it was the perfect picture to
explain why sometimes southern men don't
do right and I know cuz I'm a southern
man and I ain't been doing right most of
my life
but I wrote it this way and I don't have
to read it because the first several
chapters of all over but the shouting
are burned into my mind but I began it
with I used to stand amazed and watch
the Redbirds fight they would flash and
flutter through a sky unbelievably blue
like burning rags soaring swirling
plummeting and on the ground they were a
blur of feathers stabbing for each
other's eyes I've seen grown men stop
what they were doing stop pulling corn
or lift their head out from under the
hood of a broken-down car just to watch
it once when I was little I watch one of
those birds Peck itself to death in the
side mirror of a truck hurling itself
against the glass over and over again
until it was cracked and smeared with
blood and I asked a man who worked from
alquiler this old snuff dipping man
named Charlie Bivens I said Charlie why
do you recognize that and he told me it
was just its nature and I thought that
explained my daddy pretty well I've
talked to colleges where the first
question when a young man or young one
would shoot her hand up is what in the
world did you mean by that red bird
stuff in the middle of that but most
people figured it out most people
figured it out pretty quickly but I
can't read y'all parts the book from the
book about my mama because I will start
to cry and I and y'all back me up on
this you know here in the progressive
state like Georgia
it might be a little different but back
home in Alabama if a 6 foot 2 and 3/4
265 pound man starts to weep openly in
front of a large group of people all the
other men will drag him outside and beat
him to death so what I'll do instead is
we'll talk a little bit about it and
don't pay any attention to the program
I'd rather really rather talk with you
than talk at you so I look forward to
the questions we'll have some fun with
the questions and it takes me about a
hour to answer every question so we get
through a lot quicker how many of you
have ever tried someone is killing a
child right around
someone and this close to all these
witnesses is beating a child to death I
bet you we got social workers in here
and they have a move to live but the
reason that I act a fool up here and
that's what my mama would call it acting
a fool it's because I cannot talk about
the the sweeter and darker images in
shouting I just can't do it I just can't
so I laughed my way through it the best
I can and every now and then I'll slip
into something close to seriousness how
many of you by show of hands are married
to a southern man yes divorce does count
now by show of hands how many of you
feel like you've got a good one how many
of you are lying because they're here
those are my people you know sometimes
I'm convinced that some of my kinfolk
stayed married not out of love or
devotion or family but out of spite my
brother Sam and my sister-in-law Teresa
have been married for 25 years Sam will
tell you you know in his in moments
where he swear he knows no one's around
he just cannot imagine just cannot
imagine not having her cannot imagine
life without her she I'm pretty sure he
stayed married to him out of pity
but when it came time to write a book
about my mom I I got all puffed up about
the things I was able to do for her
you're one of the nice things that
happened after the book came out was I
was able to do some really nice things
for my family but even before the book
came out I got to I got to to buy my mom
a house we bought her a four-bedroom
brick house on a hill with central
heating air and a doorbell and it's not
a mansion but it's a really nice house
for us and a reporter from one of the
local newspapers actually a big-city
newspaper came to interview my momma
after the book came out and she asked
her a great question she said Miss Brad
what it was the best day of your life
and I got really puffed up I was sitting
in there and I thought well because I
thought for sure she'd say it was the
day my son bought me a house I felt sure
she'd say it was a day my son wrote that
book about me and handed me that
hardcover copy to honor me she thought
about it for a minute and then looked at
the woman and said well hon I believe it
was the birth of my first son and I
shouldn't have even been surprised books
and houses papering would they just
don't matter
I know that's a terrible thing to say to
a roomful of librarians but in my
mother's life books and houses are just
paper and wood and my mother's life is
proud as she might be as some of the
things I've written in my lifetime and
they seem to be really proud at the book
about my grandfather
avis man but that's just not what
matters and the reporter asked her said
well why and she said well my mother
doesn't have any self pity
so she meant this as a way to try to get
this young woman to understand her just
understand her and she said well see I
never had a doll I never had a doll
think about that for a minute I never
had a doll and then all of a sudden here
is this little man this perfect little
man I don't think he's all that handsome
myself
matter of fact I think you look like
some kind of like monkey experiment gone
terribly wrong
I hear he is all red and squiggly
looking but her he was perfect and she
spent she achieved my daddy was nowhere
around so she did what generations of
mothers have done with their babies well
going back as long as I guess there's
been babies and mothers she took the
child home to her mother and her daddy
and the next morning my grandfather
Charlie bun Durham his folk hero
larger-than-life figure told her said
Margaret you kept me up all night long
talking to that boy and the reporter
asked my mom well what were you saying
and my mom said all I was just saying
over and over again your mind your mind
so you know that's just who she is
the fact that y'all had picked the book
that I wrote about her to read as a
community is one of the nicest things
that has happened to me the state of
Arkansas picked it and the state of
mobile the state of Ohio
yeah you can tell I'm a product to the
Alabama public school system actually
doub a public school system actually was
did me just fine actually I had good
teachers I had I went to I had I learned
everything I needed to learn except math
never learned to lick still can't do
long division but mobile picked it is a
city right it's picked a VA's man it's a
citywide Reid and I and it's always an
honor to hear that but a lot of you
folks know these people already so it is
even more of an honor so there are lots
of reasons why I'm tickled to death that
y'all did this that's just one of them
now there are some problems I'm getting
to sweat so really I might start to jerk
here any minute
up here but the truth is how many of you
just have ever tried to interview your
parents about anything just talk to them
about anything and needed them to tell
you a story start to finish in an
orderly concise matter I know your mom
my Aunt Edna is a great storyteller
she is a fantastic storyteller but you
better pack a lunch but my kin folks
will not tell a story straight through
they'll tell it and then they'll say did
you see what was on the world turns
or they'll or they'll be telling a story
about you know a goat and that'll be
halfway through the story and somebody
else will walk in and she'll say yeah it
was a good story about that goat but let
me tell you a story about this goat it
takes you six months you can be
interviewing somebody July 4th and I
won't get the ending of it until
Thanksgiving dinner and my family but
the worst it ever got was you know we
published all over about the shouting
what 96 97 97 98 I I'm terrible math
yeah 97 and then a few years later we
came out with Ava's man and these are
hardback books these are New York Times
bestsellers these are these are books
that have a solid sound to them when you
drop them on a table and not one book
comes out but two books come out about
family first book honored my mother and
hinted that my grandfather was a good
man
hinted that my grandfather was a
interesting man
then avis man came out and I got to
they're not beating you back there are
they
hence why have never had any children
I've thought about having children I've
also thought about sticking my head
under a beer truck but I digress but it
when it came time to write the book
about my grandfather I found out that he
might have been the most remarkable man
that ever walked through that part of
the county he would go fishing with a
crank telephone give it 20 or 30 good
twists I know you've done this give it
20 or 30 good twists though the line
into the water shock all the fish up to
the surface efficient
he beat the mortal hell out of two
Georgia Highway patrolman and threw them
headfirst out the front door of a beer
joint called the maple on the hill his
hands were so quick he snatched
squirrels from trees and he died in 1958
a year before I was born
and I say in avis man I have never
forgiven him for that so when it came
time to build me a grandfather and to
build this this man from the dirt very
much in the way that I'd honored my
mother I tried to honor my grandfather
but while you're honoring a woman that's
never said a mean word about anybody
when you're honoring a woman that you
know that just raised her children did
the best she could that's a little
easier than honoring a man that made
liquor for 30 years
you know never got caught yet it was he
raised eight children had eight children
and got all but one grown in the teeth
of the Great Depression and they loved
him like a hero so I've got not one book
about a hero but two books about a hero
that's when my Gracie wanted to decide
it after both books had been published
to call up and say hon in books were
pretty good but I sure do wish you could
have got in one of them books at least
about that time that daddy ran over Clem
Ritter's head so what little bit of
literary career I had flashed before my
eyes because I've written two books that
honored these people and then I find out
after the second book has been published
by the way Clem Ritter was female that
my grandfather ran over Clem Ritter's
head with his truck tire as I said well
maybe you'd better tell me what happened
she said well there's not much to tell
we was little and me and your mama all
of us was coming back from town and
daddys cut down those of you who are not
of the culture that I am from should
know that a cut down is a car that has
been turned into a truck with a
blowtorch and axe and they were coming
back we said we was coming back from
from town and we was all in the cab
me and your mom and I thought great my
mama was a concocted and here she come
runnin all wild and crazy lookin out of
the weeds in the trees at the side of
the road and she ran right out in front
of Daddy's truck and Daddy ran over her
head with his truck tire what do you do
then actually I said my god what did you
do then all stories in our family are
punctuated with my god
my god what did you do then
she said well hunt they won much we
couldn't do we all got out and looked at
her and I she laid daddy's truck tired
run over her head and there she laid her
head off won't sided those of you who
haven't been to school now Bama
won't side it is I thanked spelled WOM P
decided I think there's a hyphen in
there there she laid all walks idea and
I said my god what y'all do there well
daddy picked her up and slung her back
off in the weeds
by now I figured that my next job will
involve a pick handle what y'all do then
she said well we went on home mama had
supper done you didn't you didn't try to
go to a telephone and and I knew that
was a probably a hopeless thing cause
granddaddy had probably jerked the last
one off the wall and used it fishing
said you didn't get to a telephone or
you didn't try to go somewhere and
notify the coroner or maybe even get
some medical attention for because
apparently the physical examination of
her had consisted of slinging her off in
the weeds
since they don't know we just went on
home and say you don't understand hunt
long about dark
we looked out in the yard and here she
come walking up in the yard her head
still all walks idea and it was twenty
minutes into that story before anybody
in my family my loving family bothered
to tell me that Clem Ritter was a dog
you'd have to know my hat Juanita
she's about that big said oh ya hon she
lived for years head still all walk
sided I don't think it ever didn't get
back right and then ensues a discussion
with my other aunts about whether or not
indeed the dog's head had got right
again and there was disagreement too as
to this point it took a day my people I
can go home and sit in my mother's
living room and get more entertainment
in 15 minutes then every movie ticket
overseas trip every fancy meal or this
fight I've ever had it's just more
entertaining those of you who have read
Ava's man and all over but the shouting
know that I refer to the unfortunate
time that my grandfather had to shoot
this big woman I touch on it briefly and
all over but the shouting and then
expand on it in avis man this is the way
it was told to me now it again it was
aunt Gracie Juanita who handled the
narrative Oh Gracie Juanita it's the
best name that there's ever been
she has the best name and she really is
if she's not one of the three or four
best storytellers on the planet I'm not
here but she wouldn't see herself that
way
she would never claim that it is just a
natural thing of my people the people
the foothills of the Appalachians are
the best storytellers on the planet I am
a rank amateur compared to them they can
tell a story but the story of the
shooting of the big woman came about
this way there had been a feud with by
the way as in buying here named Reardon
there had been a feud with the Reardon's
my grandfather had adopted a little man
named hoody his name was Jesse Klein's
but they called him hoody cause he
talked to the Isles hoody was harmless
he was a little bitty fella if as big as
my leg and he had had had some history
bad history with the Reardon family
ridden family also made whiskey one day
one night actually late at night all the
children are in this little house along
the Alabama Georgia line it's dark there
ain't no electricity kerosene lantern
all these girls piled up in a bed ain't
had night Juanita ain't Joe my mom I
don't think mate sue was born then I
don't think
and a car pulls up in the driveway and
just as the car pulls up in the driveway
the door bangs open and hoody looking
like Satan is digging his talons into
his back rushes in and says help me help
me mr. Charlie they've come to get me
again and he runs into the back and I
think straight out the back if there was
a backdoor and there probably was or
under the bed that point is unclear and
they hear one of the Reardon boys shout
from the yard Cyn Hootie out he stole
some whiskey and I've come to kill him
my grandfather one gonna send that
little man out to die but his Belgian
shotgun was not in the house he didn't
even have his roofing hammer his roofing
hatchet which in his hands is a
thunderbolt so he said well you can't
have him and he looked around for a
weapon anything and the only thing there
was to fight with was one of Ava's
skillets and he didn't want to die
holding a skillet in his hand
so he walked outside empty-handed
empty-handed into the bore of the
shotgun and it was just a little 410
shotgun but it was a shotgun nonetheless
and the Reardon boy was aiming it at my
grandfather's head and my grandfather
just started walking toward him
empty-handed
because he had his babies in the house
in no way was that man going to walk
into his house with a shotgun with all
those little girls in the bed so he just
walked he took he some I never saw his
face but the description they gave me of
him was fearsome taller than me then is
a rail but with those long muscles that
in these big hands huge hands I got
thirteen-year-old girl hands but these
big old hands that you can you see on
men like that and this angular face and
these blue eyes that were just fire fire
in overalls on one gallows on one Gallus
off walking into the ball of that gun
and the fella pointed it at his head and
pulled the trigger and missed him
and he snapped the breach down and
fumbled to put a new shell in and my
grandfather just started running and the
Reardon boy got the shell in and my
grandfather was close and he snapped the
breech - and my grandfather was closer
and when he pointed it my grandfather
was on him and his fist the size of
frozen turkey comes flying at his face
and he hammers him back and he snatches
the gun from his hand with the other
hand knocks the boys teeth out and then
he looks and in the gloom to the left
hand side comes this big woman out of
the shadows with a hog killing knife in
her hand about that big and she's raised
like this right here to cut his head off
and he turned and fired
I'll pick up with that Gracie Juanita
here my god
where did he shoot her grace Juanita
said well honey shot her through both
bosoms I surmise that she had been
standing sideways I said my god did it
not kill her well they put her hands
over a head and form this big circle
with her hands and said Oh Lord no hon
they was that big biggest truck tires
biggest Mexican hats and that kind of
confused me and I had to think about
that for a minute then it occurred to me
sombreros they were bigger than
sombreros
I could do this all night
the truth is sitting and listening to
family talk about family he's as much
fun as I've ever had all over but the
shouting was really hard for me to write
in parts and parts of it made me laugh
out loud book about my grandfather was
easier to write but they were great
adventures for me to interview family
and I would not take anything on earth
for that time the fact that you guys
found value in it tells me two things
one you're very nice people to you are
excellent judges of literature but I
hope those of you who haven't read all
over both shout and I hope you get to I
hope that I hope you like it I hope you
like it as a book and I hope you like it
as a piece of writing but more than that
I hope you like my people because if you
do not like my people then I have truly
failed I just failed I don't want you to
think they're too good to be true I want
you to think they're just good enough to
be true and I bet if you told me stories
about your people we would come to the
same conclusions now admittedly not
everybody is going to come off looking
that good in memoir
you know if you write about yourself you
got a beat on yourself a little bit in
it and I've I tried to beat on myself
for a whole lot until my editor finally
said enough already you beat yourself up
enough I said no I'm just getting
started but I hope that we get a chance
to talk again I really do hope that I
hope that this community reads is a
success for everybody involved I'm sure
it will because I've met the people who
are running it y'all got some fine
librarians they're not nearly as mean as
the ones I remember as a child and I'll
tell you one more story and then we'll
we'll take some questions my mother and
Charlotte you'll have to back me up on
this but have you ever heard her say
anything mean about anyone in her life
and she never wanted much really she
never wanted anything except for us but
she was fond of one thing she had the
ugliest dog that ever lived
his name was gizzard and he was named
for Lewis Grizzard
but my mama who those of you who know
the denture adventure had trouble saying
Grizzard so she called him
you know old gizzard and in truth
gizzard the dog looked a little bit like
Lewis y'all keep an eye on them
and you don't reckon out with somebody
that was married to Lewis D
because chances are pretty good if you
throw a wide enough loop you're going to
hit one of Louis's ex-wives
but gizzard gizzard had problems gizzard
lost every hair on his body from the
neck back I bet y'all are all real glad
you've already eaten to some terrible
skin condition that was like mange only
worse he was naked from the neck down or
back depending on was not he's upright
or horizontal I am NOT making this up
oh I've never had a cousin in the
audience that backed me up before
and what happened was Emma he probably
could have been cured but we like to
come up with you know a look how light
with my mama's self diagnosing her
gallbladder we like to come up with our
own remedies how many of you in here
have ever poured a gallon bucket motor
oil on a mangy dog
we like to motor all that dog to death
I'd go home for Thanksgiving I look
forward to Thanksgiving the way that
some people look forward to love picture
if you can a plate that consists of a
turkey leg that big we don't care what
the turkey looks like we think the
turkey is supposed to fall off the bone
and cornbread dressing and mashed
potatoes green beans pinto beans with a
big piece of ham floating in the middle
of it biscuits picture a plate mama got
me a special plate one year I think it
was a prison tray
which if you know some of my people is
not hard to come by and you pile that
high with all that wonderful food and
we've never had room for everybody to
sit at the table you just go sit where
you can sit you balance it on your knee
and eat and I'd go and I'd sit down in
the living room just me and this food
that if you are a bachelor and you live
by yourself trust me I would trade a
Corvette for that meal
I mean it and you just get ready to dig
in and you get a big fork full of it you
get it ready put in your mouth and here
comes that naked dog and he lays his
head which is the only part that's fuzzy
on your leg and he looks at you lovingly
you can't eat looking at that but he
lived a long time and my mother loved
him and he had a good soul that dog if I
know that sacrilege to say that I know
that Lots people tell me I'm being I'm
being sacrilegious but that dog was
almost human
that dog was smart and he loved my
mother he loved her and but he hadn't
and I'll try to say this delicately if I
can in case there's anybody here it's
congregational wholeness
or Church Christ our Baptist or
Methodist our Presbyterian and we don't
have to worry about the Lutheran's cuz
they just left but he he was a ladies
dog he was popular and he would he would
go visiting he just disappeared stay
gone two three days
come back big grin on his face he'd go
and go and go
even as he got old even as he got weak
even as he got sick he'd just all of a
sudden get this look on his face and
he'd start pulling into door and then of
course one time he went off and didn't
come back and they found him laying in
the road and at first I thought to
myself what a terrible terrible tragedy
that is and then I thought you know I
wouldn't mind going out like that myself
thank you
sure we're gonna take some time
let's uh
y'all are waitin on spec let's take some
let's take some questions okay anybody
wanna one question okay it was red birds
and blue birds yeah I think we
camouflage it better I think it's more
complicated but I mean let's face it the
south is just more complicated in
general and if you want an example of
how complicated the South is look at the
county we're in it is the best of a lot
of worlds it is beautiful here you see
why people want to come here you know
it's got beautiful lakes it's got
beautiful trees it's got still some
pasture you know you know but but at the
same time it also has some really nice
beautiful big houses you know and people
want to live here and you cannot blame
them for wanting to live here and but
this county is complicated you know and
it will wrestle with those problems as
it is wrestling with them now and and
and but you know race is more
complicated class is more complicated
the one thing that terrifies me about
southern society and I'm not talking
about the society page
is that the blue-collar base is almost
gone there are islands of great
prosperity you know you know a new car
plant opened in Lincoln Alabama and gave
a lot of people some work but a cotton
mill shut down in Jackson while
abominate took a lot of people away from
the life that they had
toward and sacrificed for so the South
has got some serious problems and I'm
just not smart enough to work them out
but I you know I do think that those
that that's that that line of
demarcation is still there but it's more
complicated new money now you know
Yankee money you know you know is you
know a lot of if you see a big house
more than likely it's not because that
family owned a lot of farmland and built
a mansion on it
now it may be it may be you know
corporation money it's just so
complicated now and Atlanta is the most
complicated of all of you know the
complicated southern cities and and
people will follow Atlanta's lead in
this they've followed their lead in
every other way and you know Gwinnett
County the surrounding areas you know
we'll work through those problems or or
not I know that the schools are crowded
here you know so I think that the south
is just not the thing that we can get
our hands around you know it used to be
that you had poor folks and they were
almost always white and black then you
had rich folks that were very seldom
anything but why well it's complicated
now you have you have migrant workers
who you know who are part of that
society
you have European experts incorporation
I mean it's just a very very complicated
thing and I I'm just not smart enough to
talk about it although I did talk about
it for ten minutes and then say a damn
thing
well usually what I leave out I choose
to no that's a good question it's very
good question what I usually choose to
leave out is the parts I can't spell
I wrote a story once about a washerwoman
in Mississippi who left her entire
fortune 150 thousand dollars as she made
a nickel dime and quarter at a time that
she left that fortune to this college
and and I was watching her raggedy Bible
and it was so raggedy that if she held
it that you know pages like a kids
notebook that they dropped you know that
the pages would just like this you know
and every book in the Bible every
chapter in verse was kind of loose-leaf
and I said in describing that Bible I
said that she binds her ragged Bible
with scotch tape to keep Corinthians
from falling out and a friend of mine
said why Corinthians I said cause i cant
spell deuteronomy
still can't forget Ecclesiastes but
southerners and you know and we can
argue about this all not I really do
believe the southerners have a beautiful
rhythm and cadence in their language and
I don't I'm not claiming that rhythm and
cadence but my people have it and their
words the selection of their words is
more poetic than I think so I mean I
hate to say it but I think so
you know there's lots of great
storytellers on the planet black folks
the Irish you know you can just keep
going with cultures that just have great
storytelling traditions but the people
of the foothills of the Appalachians
have this mix of kind of proper language
mixed with dialect and it makes a
beautiful way of speaking my mama would
not say necessarily every time
that's right hon she's telling the truth
she will look at you and say mm-hmm
she's telling God sanction that's just
prettier you know god help us it just
sounds better and I'm glad I'll have
that to draw from but it's not something
that I borrowed from other writers it's
something that truly that you know my
people have mastered in conversation now
I borrowed plenty from other writers if
I could write with the elegance of
Willie Morris if I could write with the
just a raw power of Pat Conroy if I
could do all those things I would if I
could write with just the sheer profound
beauty of Robert Penn Warren yeah I
would I can't I can write pretty
sometimes but mostly I try to write in
the language of my people and it works
it works for me may not work for
everybody
yes ma'am I'll tell you what that's just
the the writing is just the digging
taters part of storytelling there's no
magic that comes from typing there's no
magic that comes from a long hand and
there is sure no magic in a IBM ThinkPad
you know there's no magic in that that
is the digging tailors part the hard
part of storytelling if I could just
talk my books I would but you can't what
writing does is gives you a little more
flexibility and a little more time I
don't have a lot of time to shape my
thoughts up here in front of you if I'm
sitting at home and I got all day to
write three or four pages five or six
pages I'm going to have more time to
search my memory for the sayings and the
language and the rhythms and the
cadences that I want to use I have more
time to think about writers that I've
loved you know great writers Eudora
Welty I've got more time to think about
a line from Faulkner that might be
appropriate you know as far as the
rhythm of the story
you're not the words themselves meant
the rhythm of it I have time so really
the writing isn't easier than the
talking it's just it's just you know
it's worked at I hate typing I can't
type I do this and I always have but if
I was rich like just thinking filthy
rich you know I just I just I'd get me
somebody to talk but unfortunately that
ain't gonna happen
that was unfortunate beat the hell out
of us what she did right oh I'm sure I'm
sure he thought about it the story that
she eluded that thank you very that she
alluded to was was my and I'll get in
trouble for telling this but I wrote it
so I don't see how I could get much more
trouble and and your mom my Edna told me
this this story and what happened my
granddaddy allowed this traveling woman
named Blackie Lee to to come and wash
her clothes at his house now in truth he
went on to work but she was there and
the way the story goes my grandma was
picking cotton and had all the kids with
her at a farm not far too far away and a
cut of a relative named sis walked up to
Ava in the field and said Ava did you
get some silk stockings I said no of
course not
and C us said well you know I drove by
y'all's house and I saw some silk
stockings on the line my grandmother
walked home
saw this woman on the porch walked over
to the woodpile picked up the axe
threatened to chop down our own door
when the woman wouldn't open it woman
did open the door my grandmother went in
and this is the way it was told to me
quote mama beat her all through the
house beat her out into the yard beat
her so bad that her hands swelled up so
big she couldn't fit him in her
apron-pocket that's one of those details
that lets you know it's true beat her
down to the road flagged down a car that
was coming flagged the car down jerked
the car door open through that woman in
and told the driver get her on out of
here and a man said yes ma'am so yeah he
later on
I think my grandmom tried to beat my
granddaddy to death but it turned out
all right
and they thought God did they fight over
the years and people always said Ava why
did you stay with him why did you stay
with him and she always told people
cause he talked to me so maybe that
explains a lot
anybody can appreciate a pretty man but
not anybody can appreciate a I'm so far
from being an expert on that I'm truly
am NOT I think everybody finds their own
Road that you know that they're there I
think everybody finds their own way and
that this was always one of those
businesses where you could find your own
way and that doctrine doctrine is not
necessarily a thing that applies itself
well and I I've known reporters that you
know that finished high school barely
and then I've known reporters that have
master's degrees and doctorates and you
know I just think it I just think it
it's hard to say in the past the
business was open to everyone the
business was open to everyone it's
harder and harder now to to enter the
business without a some kind of formal
education and you know they whether or
not that is a journalism education or
not
you know people argue about that too
it's kind of like that other question I
could talk for ten minutes not say
anything intelligent it's a good
question I just don't know
I don't know again you know I would have
loved to have I would loved to have had
more formal education in every way I
mean I'd love to have had it I just
didn't get to get it I guess I could
have put my nose to the grindstone and
tried to got a scholarship or something
but you know I just wasn't that kind of
student I was the kind of student they
thought well see y'all to do it and but
you know and successful I don't know I
mean I love I love writing and I love
going out to talk to people and I love
to stick my notebook in my back pocket
and go to do that process but you know
it is a complicated business now and I
truly am not qualified to talk about it
thank you anybody else yes ma'am
oh okay that's what happened with that
is my grandma I mean my father the light
one of the well the last time I saw him
alive he was very sick with tuberculosis
and cirrhosis and he had wasted away and
when I saw him there's one of those
things I can't talk about very well when
I saw him he was near death
and he said he'd always been very proud
of his looks he's a pretty man and he
said it's all over but the shouting for
me now anymore so it's partly that it
was partly that and it was also just
that all over but the shouting means
something to us it means that you're at
a point in your life where you feel you
can draw a breath and shout or yell or
shake your fist at the sky I think it
was all those things that made me decide
to call it that but mostly probably the
first thing right there I have exactly
I know it wasn't in one story but but it
was a succession of things I was lucky
that I was at first a sports writer and
you know I got to cover in my first or
second year my first full year of being
a reporter I got to cover Richard Petty
I got to cover Cale Yarborough you know
I got to cover a stock car racing at
Talladega I got covered college football
and you know to be paid to go to games
and and to get a good seat for free that
seemed to me like a pretty good
arrangement and and it was the
excitement of those stories more than
anything that you know they were
exciting you know it might have been
different if I'd had to cover if I'd had
to cover something that put me to sleep
but you know I never did I was a sports
writer mostly for a very long time and
then when I left that it seemed like I
got a chance to do some really exciting
stories outside sports and I just never
you know it was exciting it was very
seldom dull it is very seldom Bindo and
yeah I'll be writing stories the rest of
my life and they may be book length or
they may be magazine length but I doubt
very serious if I'm going to chase any
dull ones then we'll go here let me go
here first that is a very good question
and I don't know exactly I think you
know I'm just not real astute tonight it
may be that I'm tired but I think I
figured out that you could tell a story
you could write it down in the same
beautiful way that people tell stories
the same beautiful way that people tell
stories in the vernacular of my people
now don't get me wrong I don't write our
hope I don't write folksy but the
sayings you know the language is so
pretty that it bleeds into you know the
writing that I do and I don't think I
let that happen
early on because you know I was rigid
and you know as the years went by more
and more
Prabhat crept into the work because I
began to see value in it I began to see
by reading people like Larry McMurtry
you know reading Lonesome Dove by
reading you know the great kind of
stylist you know with these great voices
and powerful voices and I think I began
to realize that it is okay to let voice
your own voice seize control of the
writing and it was a gradual gradual
process and is still going on you know I
but you know the thing it happens to you
about writing and this is honest to god
truth is you you reach a point maybe
when you're in your 30s where you think
you know the guy you know I might be
pretty good at this and then you reach a
point in your later 30s when you think
well I don't know and then you turn 40
and then all of a sudden you were
utterly and absolutely convinced you
don't know what you're doing and I'm
convinced that by the time I'm 50 I'll
probably be sitting in a corner afraid
to touch the keyboard and by the time
I'm 60 I'll be in Milledgeville now I've
been in Milledgeville and I met some
nice people there
but I'm afraid that that you know I just
get less and less sure of what I'm doing
and I don't think that's unusual I know
a lot of really fine writers it'll tell
you that the more they do it the scared
or they are of it and I'm scared of it I
really am but god I'd love to do it
still let me go yes ma'am nothing that I
can apply to my life my mother is
without God I've known her to use God
one time in my life she does not talk
bad about other people no matter how bad
they treat her well sometimes she gets a
little mad at us you know but she very
seldom talks bad about other people and
she occasionally gets mad to get a
little mad at her sister sometimes and
they'll have hurt feelings but they love
each other so much and they are so close
to each other that it's almost like that
is allowed it's okay to say something
harsh to your sister occasionally and
they'll pout and they'll go off and
they'll be mad for you know week or a
month or a year you know but they love
each other so much and they depend on
each other so much that they feel they
can do that but my mother my mother
doesn't give up on people my mother
believes that there's dignity and
everything I'm just not good like her
I'm just not I would love to think that
I I'd love to think I've learned things
and I can apply to my own life but I'm
I'm a train wreck you know I'm not a bad
train wreck I'm that train wreck you
don't kill nobody but it's still the
train wreck
but I'm just not like her I would love
to pretend I would love to pretend that
I soaked up things from her that I can
make myself a better man but I've
operated from fear and anger and
bitterness fleeting joy I think like a
lot of us and I just I just ain't that
good I'd love again believe my love to
lie about that but I can't write good
cuz we're not gonna talk about that you
go ahead right now that part of my life
is over and I
I the truth is I've got two books to
write for Knopf and I love that
publishing house and it's been very good
to me and it has changed literally
changed my life and I look forward to
bringing in the books that I promised to
write for them and writing books down
the road for them and I'm going to do
I'm going to write until I wind up in
that corner you know scared to write
anymore but it just doesn't do any good
it just doesn't do any good to keep
talking about it
it just doesn't I am going to bring my
books in on time and then I'm going to
do something I haven't done in a very
long time nothing
you just find yourself writing the same
four pages over two point eight or you
just pretty much state like it the other
thing is you carry like in your back
pocket like when you think of a little
way of things I have no idea what the
first part of that question was I'm
kidding it's not right there
I tell you the truth do I feel like I
gained personally from it when I wrote
the introduction all over both shout and
I puffed my chest out and said in no way
is this book gonna be a vehicle for
healing and of course you know you're
halfway through and the next thing you
know of course that's what's happening
but I didn't plan on it being that way
yeah and you can and I thought to myself
first I need to go back and rewrite that
introduction but the truth is people
could see it people knew exactly what
happened and people knew exactly what
happened as far as writing down things
that I hear and other sayings I don't do
it as much as I used to when I was
younger I would even write like if I was
reading a book and I saw a great line if
I heard a great line in a song you know
I would write them down and then it
occurred to me now because the great
lines you just remember I mean you know
like the most beautiful love song ever
written is Merle Haggard's that's the
way love goes and you know it begins
I've been throwing horseshoes over my
left shoulder and then there's that
beautiful line where he says losing
makes me sorry but you say honey don't
worry
there's just eloquence and beauty in
everything that's ever been written down
the Bible Shakespeare you know even
though Shakespeare plumb evades me but
the words are beautiful
you know Bartlett's book of quotations I
can spend years years not months I mean
you could I could read it over and over
again for years
there's just beauty in the language and
there's beauty and everything that we we
hear and that's what being a writer is
is I believe
is finding that and and finding your own
Cadence's and rhythms and voice and and
applying it but now that i've got books
on my shelf where i've got written
inside the first cover you know look at
page so and so you know and and i just
don't do it as much anymore
I guess because mainly I just I just
have convinced myself that there's just
such pretty words out there there'll
always be pretty words to inspire you
thank you